when I started working out when I was a
kid I was weighed about 130 pounds and I
was six foot one it's a thin kid and I
smoked a lot I wasn't in good shape and
I went to the gym and it was Bloody
embarrassing you know people would come
over and help me with the goddamn
weights here's how you're supposed to
use this you know it was humiliating and
maybe I was pressing 65 pounds or
something at that point you know but
what am I going to do I'm going to lift
up 150 pounds and injure myself right
off the bat no I had to go in there and
strip down and put my skinny goddamn
self in front of the mirror and think
son of a [ __ ] there's all these
monsters in the gym who've been lifting
weights for 10 years and I'm struggling
to get 50 pounds off the bar tough luck
for me but I could lift 50 pounds and it
wasn't very very long until I could lift
75 and well you know how it goes but and
I never injured myself when I was lit
weightlifting and the reason for that
was I never pushed myself past where I
knew I could go and I pushed myself a
lot you know I gained 35 pounds of
muscle in about three years in
University